Radio Foot International, le
Café des Sports. Hugo
Moissonnier.
Bonjour à toutes et bonjour à
tous, bienvenue dans le café
des sports de Radio Foot
International, venez vous euh,
régaler à la télévision sur
France 24 en direct sur
Facebook, le Facebook live ou
bien à l'ancienne en écoutant
cette bonne vieille radio, ce
bon vieux transistor sur euh,
RFI car après tout euh, ce sont
dans les vieilles marmites ou
les vieux pots qu'ont fait les
meilleures euh, confitures, la
preuve nous sommes en
20vingt-trois et on va encore
mettre euh, sur l'Ardo au menu
du jour Messi et Ronaldo dans
le Café euh des sports, maillot
du pays sur le dos les deux
papilles font de la résistance.
On l'a constaté hier, euh
Ronaldo Messi impossible de se
débarrasser d'eux. Ils ont
toujours des records à battre,
des limites à repousser et des
joutes euh Gonot contre Barré
alimenté. Bonjour Emine.
Bonjour et comme vous le savez,
il est mal barré. Vous l'avez
comment dire? Préparée depuis
combien de temps depuis
deux-milledix? Depuis euh le
premier Café des Sports? Bien
évidemment, il parlait des
retraités et puis typiquement
lorsqu'il m'a aperçu là, il
s'est caché. Parce que il a
plu. Comme l'avait enterré. Et
finalement, il voit que il se
rajeunit, il s'est revigoré.
Alors petit changement quand
même euh, petite nouveauté pour
ce café des sports du vendredi.
Vous êtes arrivé, vous êtes
installé avant Xavier. Ça c'est
extrêmement rare. D'habitude,
vous arrivez le le dernier sur
le plateau et là c'est
finalement euh Xavier qui s'est
fait devant Bonjour à tous, oui
oui. Là euh l'histoire de Baré,
on me l'avait pas faite depuis
euh une éternité. Oui ben c'est
drôle, c'est drôle, c'est
original, c'est c'est très fin,
on on s'en lasse pas, merci
beaucoup Rémy. Pour éviter la
la vaisselle cassée ce
vendredi, nos deux sages du
jour seront d'abord, bonjour
Yoro. Bonjour Hugo, bonjour à
tous, un petit coup à qui nous
écoute depuis Dakar. Il a été
président de la convention des
jeunes reporters du Sénégal. Eh
bien on la salue et on on
espère qu'elle va comment dire?
Après ce ce café des sports. Je
compte sur vous euh mais sur un
autre sage, le chef adjoint du
service des sports, le Frédéric
salut tout le monde euh la voix
des auditeurs des rôles aussi.
Oui je salue Rémi on a dit on a
dit Frédéric Sutton vous
laissez ça vous laissez ce
téléphone mon cher euh Rémi
mais évidemment vous participez
aussi à ce café des sports sur
euh Facebook. Je vous parle euh
euh depuis le début de cette
émission de football et de euh
derrière les fourneaux
l'Angleterre n'oserait jamais
défier l'Italie bien évidemment
mais en matière de ballon rond
c'est autre chose. La preuve
les trois lions se sont
imposées hier à Naples, deux
buts à un en ouverture des
éliminatoires de l'Euro, un
euro remporté bien sûr par
l'Italie récemment mais la
Squadra elle inquiète euh, elle
a raté les deux derniers
mondiaux et on se demande si
elle ne rattrape pas le
prochain euro. Enfin il
semblait promis un avenir
radieux il était un prodige, un
génie précoce, le jeune, Julian
Nagazman a finalement été
renvoyé du bahut et privé de
dessert comme le gamin qu'il
est encore le jeune coach
allemand ne finira pas la
saison sur le banc du Bayern de
Munich. C'est Thomas Tuchel,
vieille connaissance du
football français qui va
prendre sa place, c'est la
cerise sur le gâteau d'un café
des sports préparé par Sarah
Loubakouche, Yann Bourdolas et
réalisé bien sûr par le maestro
Laurence Alardon.
Elle est d'abord l'apéritif
avant les commandes, les
éliminatoires de la CAN2023, la
route qui mène en en Côte
d'Ivoire, eh bien la RDC
l'emprunte enfin, Frédéric,
cette route, ce ce chemin, elle
s'est remise même euh sur le
droit chemin. Oui, il est, il
était temps, hein, pour les les
léopards deux premiers matchs
face au Gabon, puis au Soudan,
le réveil euh non pas à
Kinshasa, le stade des martyrs
n'est pas aux normes, mais euh
à Lubumbashi, euh ils ont battu
effectivement ce ce vendredi la
la Mauritanie, trois buts à un,
des buteurs, Gael Kakuta,
Cédric euh Bakambu et Arthur
euh Massakou, trois buts à un,
la RDC toujours dernière de son
groupe, mais elle se relance
effectivement, trois points, et
là, dans quelques jours, il y a
le match retour en Mauritanie,
si jamais il venait à à gagner
à nouveau les les léopards, il
serait complètement relancé
dans la course à la
qualification. Parce que là on
joue la fin des matchs aller,
troisième journée des
éliminatoires, et euh le début
des matchs retour, euh la
journée des éliminatoires de la
CAN2023. Rémi, la RDC se
relance, il était temps et
c'est plutôt logique. On voyait
mal les les léopards euh pour
suivre euh foncer, continuer à
foncer dans le mur. Il faut
dire savoir que même quand la
CAN se joue peut-être euh à
cinquante-neuf équipes. Donc on
peut même prendre d'autres
pays. La RDC ne réussit pas à
se qualifier. Donc c'était
quand même devenu terrible. Et
maintenant cette vraie
c'est vrai
que quand même on
aime bien les voir danser et
bien évidemment le et autres
mais cependant je peux pas. On
aime bien aussi leur
footballeur c'est vrai que bien
joué on peut le dire et
d'ailleurs surtout c'est le
troisième but qui est
merveilleux mais il faut savoir
que là on ne peut pas se
réjouir parce que on ne peut
pas aujourd'hui dire que la RDC
est guérie dans la mesure où la
RDC a joui plus de soixante-dix
minutes en supériorité
Expulsion effectivement euh
d'un Mauritanien hein la
vingt-deuxième. À la 22e et
quand on voit justement aussi à
la deuxième mi-temps cette RDC
a été largement bousculée alors
qu'elle était en supériorité et
du coup je me suis dit
d'ailleurs que cela était
beaucoup plus proche de euh
raccrocher de l'égalisation
mauritanienne plutôt que même
le troisième but. Oui mais
alors pour moi pour l'instant
je me dis quand même que avec
des sarbres peut apporter
encore quelque chose dans le
sable du champagne mais
cependant il n'y a pas encore
ce qu'on peut dire
véritablement les euh ces
léopards n'ont pas encore des
dents assez aiguisées. Oui ben
justement avec un sabre on peut
les les aiguiser un peu plus
vite, Yoro Mangara en même
temps voir la Mauritanie euh
causer des soucis à la RDC
c'est pas illogique, la
Mauritanie euh qui vise une
troisième canne de rang qui
faisait partie des équipes de
tête de de cette poule, un
sacré client. La Mauritanie
fait un excellent travail
depuis sept 8 ans euh c'est qui
avait démarré ce travail, il a
fait 6 années, voire sept
années à la tête de Patrice
Neveu aussi qui avait fait du
du bon travail en amont avec un
Martin ils ont fait deux coupes
d'Afrique des nations, il y a
il y a Abdoul qui est arrivé,
qui continue, ils essaient de
trouver euh de bons joueurs
pour rehausser un petit peu le
niveau de leur championnat avec
euh euh le FC Noa Dibout qui
essaie de quand même euh d'être
compétitif euh dans ces
compétitions africaines, ils
ont beaucoup de joueurs
nationaux soit des Sénégalais
qui acceptent de jouer pour la
Mauritanie ou même des
Mauritaniens qui sont nés ici
en France et qui vont jouer
pour ce ce pays. je crois que
aujourd'hui il y a des pays qui
commencent à impressionner, qui
m'impressionnent moins euh dans
ce qu'ils font, c'est la
Mauritanie, la Gambie et
peut-être aussi la
Guinée-Bissau. C'est des petits
pays qu'on entendait pas
parler, mais aujourd'hui qui
sont là euh dans ces
compétitions africaines, que ce
soit que ce soit en Coupe
d'Afrique des Nations, et même
dans les que vous pouvez
commencer des compétitions
interclubs. Oui, ils ont de
bons exemples en Afrique de
l'Ouest euh à suivre un grand
frère Saluons aussi. Saluons
aussi la quand même de d'un
pays dont on ne parle pas
beaucoup et qui est en train
également aussi de montrer euh
un très beau visage à savoir la
République centrafricaine. Oui.
On a pas beaucoup parlé de la
République qui a battu
Madagascar et qui s'est relancé
également
elle est magnifique. Salut à
vous!
Mais quand même euh Xavier la
RDC. C'était intéressant quand
ils sont allés chercher
Sébastien Dessapes, faut
rappeler qu'il était sous
contrat avec Niort et qui donc
il avait une clause dans son
contrat, qui l'autorisait à à
casser ce contrat, à quitter
son club pour prendre une
sélection africaine et donc il
a accepté de relever ce ce défi
de la République démocratique
du Congo euh face euh à
laquelle beaucoup euh ont
échoué ces dernières années. Et
c'était même pas à la dernière
d'Afrique des Nations. Donc là
c'était indispensable de
gagner, c'est vrai que ça a pas
été euh flamboyant mais
important. Voilà, ils ont
gagné, donc voilà, ils sont
relancés, là maintenant il va
falloir les confirmer euh en
Mauritanie, ce qui sera pas
facile. Mais quand on voit le
potentiel de ce pays, quand on
voit le potentiel de cette
équipe, euh les résultats
qu'ils avaient ces dernières
années étaient tout à fait euh
en dessous de ceux qu'on peut
attendre. Les éliminateurs de
la CAN à suivre euh bien sûr
euh sur euh RFI notamment en
écoutant Mondial Sport ce
week-end ce samedi et et ce
dimanche, le coup d'envoi,
vingt-et-une heures trente
temps universel.
Ont-ils une date de péremption?
Vont-ils s'arrêter un jour?
S'arrêter de marquer, d'être
célébré, de jouer au football
tout simplement. Mais si
Ronaldo, Ronaldo, Messi vous en
reprendrez bien un peu de ce
duel de titans qui nourrit, je
le disais, la rivalité euh
Xavier Barré, Rayming Gonot
depuis 2010 depuis la création
de Radio Foot et il gagnait
même des des ballons d'or ces
deux-là avant. Hier les deux
monstres ont encore brillé. On
est en 2023 avec le maillot de
leur sélection respective sur
le dos, Frédéric Sud oui avec
des des records encore hein
pour euh pour l'un et l'autre
alors Cristiano Ronaldo euh
c'est un match éliminatoire
pour l'Euro 202-quatre,
Portugal Lincoln bon euh pour
la et là au bout de 13 ans
toujours pas la prononcer. Non
ça ça on n'y arrive pas. Euh
non il a battu le record
mondial de sélection,
cent-quatre-vingt-dix-sept
sélections, il était à égalité
avec un un Covetien, euh il le
dépasse euh désormais deux il
en est à 120 en sélection euh
oui on pensait que ça s'était
terminé à la Coupe du monde,
l'histoire de Cristiano Ronaldo
eh bien c'est reparti pour un
tour et Lionel Messi lui
pendant ce temps-là bien il
fêtait son titre mondial euh à
Buenos Aires euh match amical
euh tranquille et là ben il a
marqué lui aussi un superbe
coup franc euh trente-cinq ans
son huit-centième but en
carrière. Tiano Ronaldo on est
à huit-cent-trente en carrière
Donc il continue tous les deux
à battre c'était contre le le
Panama pour les pour les
argents donc euh grand joueur,
grande performance, grand
record mais aussi et oui ça va
avec euh grand problème.
c'était déjà le le cas en club
pour Cristiano Ronaldo, ça
s'est un peu euh réglé du côté
de Manchester, mais si lui en
ce moment il est contesté à
Paris, Ronaldo était contesté
en sélection pour Messi La Saba
un petit peu mieux mais on on
se dit que la page elle va
bientôt se tourner quand même,
il va falloir la tourner euh
mais comment on digère de tels
champions ou l'Argentine? Les
les deux situations sont pas du
tout les mêmes. Euh puisque
clairement, c'était un match de
gala. Un match amical organisé
pour présenter la coupe du
monde au public argent sa
retraite. Oui il a dit qu'il
irait jusqu'à la Copa America
deux-mille-vingt-quatre mais
bon euh c'est c'est disons
qu'il en fait pas il il le
clame pas sur tous les toits.
Cristiano Ronaldo lui on était
clairement à la fin d'un cycle,
on commence un nouveau cycle
avec un nouveau sélectionneur,
Roberto Martinez à la place
donc euh de Fernando Santos euh
une sélection portugaise qui
joue des matchs euh alors c'est
des matchs mais ça ressemble un
peu à des matchs de gala
puisque c'est le Lichtenstein
et puis euh dans trois jours ce
sera aussi une autre petite
équipe eh ben voilà. Et c'est
l'occasion de lancer des
jeunes, vous en avez plein
bourré de talents au Portugal,
vous avez un nouveau
sélectionneur, eh bien non, on
fait jouer Cristiano Ronaldo
pour qu'il batte ses records.
Mais quel quel intérêt?
L'intérêt c'est que le Portugal
est une équipe performante au
prochain Euro, c'est pas que
Cristiano Ronaldo bat ses
records. J'avoue que la
politique euh de la fédération
portugaise me dépasse
complètement. Des audi
rebondissent là sur ce que vous
dites, Zephira et le Burundi il
nous dit carton rouge à CR7 euh
qui sort les dents quand on en
a pas besoin et que ça compte
pas, c'est en quart de finale
de Coupe du monde qu'on
attendait. Bien sûr. Vous voyez
euh nous sommes pour une
réforme des retraites euh mais
pour avancer l'âge de départ à
la retraite de certains
footballeurs, Emile Gonaud. Et
même votre Ronaldo adoré. Je
crois que Lionel Messi a déjà
pris la retraite trois fois. Et
il est revenu chaque fois, déjà
quelqu'un qui ment à tout
instant, ce n'est pas bien. Et
là maintenant
adversaire que l'Argentine a
trouvé et qu'il trouve que
c'est bien c'est un pays qui
est reconnu pour
attendez c'est
match c'est un adversaire
le Panama ils ont joué ils ont
joué tout ce en dehors de ça
donc Xavier Baré nous dit que
par exemple ça c'était un match
de gala on peut pas faire un
match de gala puisque le
sélectionneur n'était même pas
là. On a pris des vendeurs à la
sauvette. On a pris également
aussi trois jardiniers puisque
l'équipe du Panama ça devait
jouer avec pas répondre à la
question. Est-ce que euh on en
a pas évidemment qui continuent
à battre des records à être euh
faut pas passer à autre chose
d'un côté comme de l'autre. De
toutes les façons on fait pour
passer à autre chose. Mais on
on a bien vu que Cristiano
Ronaldo lui il continue
toujours euh à être performant
et bien évidemment dans tous
les championnats tous les
champion mais cette fois-ci il
est pas au niveau des autres
joueurs euh portugais euh
attaquants, les Fernandes, les
Ramos, les Bernardo Silva. Ah
ben si vous voulez, si vous
voulez dire ça pour un joueur
qui vient de claquer deux coups
francs, je vous rappelle quand
même que lorsque
un club et un bien évidemment
euh euh en sélection, donc ça
fait deux coups francs, vous
n'allez pas me contredire ça.
Ça fait que à une certaine
période, on me disait que
Lionel Messi est celui qui
savait créer des actions, mais
je me rends compte que jusqu'à
présent, quand même, pendant
qu'on appelait Cristiano Ronal
que Messi dans tout ça il a
marqué 108 buts sur penalty. Je
me rends compte que Lionel
Messi a marqué quand même
attendez trois buts de la main
qui sont comptabilisés.
Cristiano Ronaldo n'a jamais
marqué de la main. Donc à une
certaine période, laissez
Monaco. L'assistance vidéo
Merci.
Là là où on est en train de
dans la rivalité qu'on en est à
compter les buts euh plus ou
moins inventés de la main et
les autres. Yo! Va falloir
élever le niveau de cette euh
tôt ou tard. Peut-être que vous
aurez ce problème-là un jour
avec euh Sadio Mané du côté du
Sénégal. Comment est-ce qu'on
lâche la main d'une
intelligent, il pourra il
pourra partir de lui-même.
C'était ce que je voulais
entendre. Voilà et même je
crois que Messi ou Cristiano
Ronaldo tôt ou tard ils
partiront. Après comme l'a dit
trente-huit ans Ronaldo moi je
croyais que c'était le moment
ou jamais. Euh pour lui de
décrocher après tout ce qu'il a
fait pour ce pays, il a gagné
quand même aux championnats
d'Europe avec le Portugal. Il a
tout gagné en club. Il a tout
en tant que sportif de haut
niveau. Aujourd'hui il aurait
pu laisser les rameaux euh
voilà profiter aussi euh de ce
moment pour euh pouvoir écrire
leur histoire avec cette
élection portugaise. Parce que
lui quand même il a il a battu
un record de Pauleta qui était
vié de plus de 20 ans à qui
d'aujourd'hui il est le
meilleur buteur de cette
sélection. Il a tout gagné et
euh le potentiel énorme qu'il y
a au Portugal doit pousser
Cristiano Ronaldo à décrocher
et à se consacrer à son club.
Tout comme Léo Messi hein parce
que Messi on le voit qu'un club
il a des fulgurances mais c'est
à coup, c'est une fois tous les
là vous dimanches. Une fois
tous les dix matchs euh il
n'est pas brillant comme il l'a
été avec euh Barcelone. Oui a
priori ne semble pas vouloir le
lâcher. Il a gagné la
Il devait justement après la
coupe du monde annoncer aux
Argentins que c'était la fin
pour Messi avait la sélection
Albiceles. Mais même le le PSG
euh s'accroche un peu au
pouvoir marketing de de Messi
en tout cas ce que Ronal tous
les regards convergés presque
tous les équipes du Paris
Saint-Germain. Au niveau
mondial ristot. Au niveau
mondial. Messi et Cristiano
Ronaldo aussi d'ailleurs ça
reste des marques très très
fortes. Et c'est pour ça que le
PSG veut le garder et c'est
pour ça qu'effectivement il y a
d'autres clubs candidats pour
euh pour euh le faire venir,
voire même le Barça, pour le
faire revenir. Euh ça reste des
des des marques exceptionnelle.
Maintenant euh la question que
pose Hugo c'est quel intérêt de
les maintenir dans des
sélections qu'ils doivent
préparer un nouveau cycle? Et
là je vous rejoins en
différenciant les deux cas hein
dans le cas de Messi on est
dans un match de gala prévu
pour présenter la Coupe du
monde aux supporters argentins.
Donc euh on est pas du tout
dans la même situation que
Christiano Ronaldo, là on est
dans un match de compétition,
le début d'un cycle avec un
nouveau sélectionneur et on
maintient Christiano Ronaldo
alors qu'il y a comme ça le
Ramos à faire jouer, qui a
André Silvault les matchs on
verra enfin les matchs
importants officiels vont
arriver en Argentine euh. Bah
ils arriveront pour les
éliminatoires de la Coupe du
monde de vingt-six, mais avant
la Copa America donc euh on
verra effectivement à ce
moment-là mais euh mais Messi
pour le moment ils ils se
déclarent pas beaucoup sur ce
sujet-là. En tout cas voilà
quand on a de de tels monstres
ben on crée des monstres hein
justement. C'est un petit peu
le le problème entre guillemets
que que posent ces deux
joueurs. Euh Frédéric Sutaud
euh est retombé sur le plateau
mais là les les téléspectateurs
ils ils commentent le match de
boxe euh si c'est Benaminou,
Xavier Barré, euh qu'est-ce
qu'il a euh contre C R sept?
Elle a Jeremy est acculée par
Xavier dans les cordes, il
cherche à trouver de l'air, euh
Younous, vive Rémi, euh Rémi a
raison euh bon voilà, c'est
parfait. Voilà, comme
d'habitude, je gagne toujours.
La la la vieille recette du du
Café des Sports, elle fait
toujours euh comme j'ai
toujours dit, vous savez, moi
je juge des joueurs sur
beaucoup de stades. J'ai
constaté que Cristiano Ronaldo
est parti pour revenir du Real
Madrid. Eh bien, il est parti,
réussir bel et bien, il ne
serait-ce que la Juve. À à la
Juve, où il a été à Manchester
United, mais je me rends compte
aujourd'hui que Messi est venu
à Paris Saint-Germain, il n'a
pas réussi et que justement
contre le Bayern on est
toujours là en huitième siècle
Cristiano Ronaldo lui il est
parti maintenant de telle sorte
que on parlait de l'Arabie
Saoudite, ce gars-là
prochainement il va faire que
le championnat du Tchad
peut-être quand il aura 50 ans
devienne Hélène regardez comme
le dit un proverbe africain en
bon cultivateur peut
transformer le désert en
paradis mais laissez les
Tchadiens quand même tranquille
parce que c'est la deuxième
fois je crois que déjà il y a
15 jours vous parliez du
championnat du Tchad
ironisé
sur euh la carrière de
Cristiano Ronaldo. Je viens
toujours avec pour essayer de
signé en Angola hein. Allez on
salue effectivement euh on
avait eu euh Rivaldo en Angola
et on salue les les Tchadiens
qui nous regardent ou qui nous
écoutent, le football de
sélection et un autre champion,
Manu, au menu du Café des
Sports, on passe à la deuxième
tournée.
Bon, on va pas se mentir, on va
descendre un petit peu de de de
quelques crans en termes de
champions. Il a du talent,
c'est indéniable, il bat lui
aussi des records, mais la
carrière d'Harry Kane, c'est de
lui dont je parle, elle nous
laisse pour le moment un goût
amer. On va parler
spécifiquement d'Harry Cain
dans quelques instants, mais
d'abord, le match de son
équipe, hier, la belle
performance et même performance
historique, première victoire
en Italie pour l'Angleterre
depuis
mille-neuf-cent-soixante-et-un.
Personne n'était né. En 1961,
autour de de cette table, voyez
ça nous fait remonter très très
loin. Euh Kein a marqué sur euh
penalty euh d'Iklan Race
également. Le buteur italien il
se nomme Reteggi. Alors c'est
un Argentin, vous ne le
connaissez pas, c'est un
Argentin qui joue au Mexique,
qui ne maîtrise pas plus que
moi la langue de dents. Son
arrière-grand-parent italien.
Non, il joue au Mexique, mais
il est prêté par Boca Juniors
euh voilà. Donc c'est peut-être
ce qu'on peut interpréter comme
un aveu de faiblesse pour la la
squadra de Zura, qui est
championne d'Europe en titre,
mais qui a surtout raté les les
deux derniers mondiaux.
Champion d'Europe avec trois
Brésiliens, il faut le rappeler
aussi hein. Effectivement
qui étaient titulaires hier
aussi. La Squadra qui débute
euh mal, alors certes contre
l'Angleterre, sa campagne de
qualification euh pour l'Euro,
faut-il euh s'inquiéter euh et
imaginer un nouveau fiasco pour
euh les Italiens? Yo Mangara?
Je sais pas parce qu'ils ont
fait une piètre première
mi-temps, mais en deuxième
période, c'était quand même une
belle équipe qu'on a vu jouer
et qui a marqué un superbe but.
C'est tout euh il fallait la
faire et le but était
exceptionnel. Après moi
j'attends de voir une Italie
cohérente sur quatre-vingt-dix
minutes et depuis l'Euro, ça on
l'a pas vu. On a vu une équipe
qui a joué une mi-temps hier et
peut-être qu'ils pourront
s'appuyer sur cette mi-temps
justement pour essayer de se
qualifier au prochain euro
parce que sinon ce sera un
grand fiasco pour une équipe
comme l'Italie qui a toujours
été là dans les grands moments
du football européen. La
question en creux euh Xavier
Baré qui se c'est ce que
l'Italie est encore une euh une
grande nation du du football.
Ce qui est paradoxal puisque au
niveau des clubs ça va très
bien depuis très longtemps. Oui
mais parce qu'il y a
soixante-dix% de joueurs donc
il y a que trente % de joueurs
sélectionnables et quand vous
prenez les grands clubs par
exemple Naples euh il y avait
qui? Il y a le gardien, il y a
Politano et et puis euh il y a
le capitaine là, dit Lorenzo,
voilà. Donc euh c'est c'est
très compliqué de faire une
équipe nationale. Quand vous
avez très peu de joueurs
sélectionnables dans les grands
clubs et que vous en avez pas à
l'étranger. Et ils ont beaucoup
de blessés aussi. Ça compte un
pays de football comme
l'Italie, quatre fois champ
comment ça se fait qu'on a pas
euh de produire des joueurs sur
la formation depuis de
nombreuses années, alors ils
ont essayé d'essayer de
rattraper ça mais ils ont
beaucoup de retard par rapport
aux autres pays occidentaux et
puis surtout parce qu'ils ont
fait trop de business pendant
les années quatre-vingt-dix
2-mille ils sont venus par
exemple un club comme Loudez à
soixante-dix ou 80 joueurs sous
contrat, beaucoup de
sud-américains, des Africains
aussi et ils les vendent et en
plus comme c'est le même patron
que le club euh alors c'est
plus que grenade ils l'ont
revendu maintenant, c'est plus
eux mais que Watf ils font des
passerelles entre les clubs
pour à chaque fois euh faire du
business. Mais ils oublient le
football, ils oublient la base
du football. Et pendant ce
temps-là ben le football
italien, en tout cas le
football de la nation italienne
se dégrade et et quand vous
voyez le groupe dans lequel ils
sont, il y a l'Ukraine qui sont
champions d'Europe des 20 ans
en 2019, donc il y a une belle
génération qui arrive aussi
maintenant. Ils ont la
Macédoine qui les avait
éliminés en barrage de la
dernière Coupe du monde. Donc
ils sont pas sûrs d'être au
prochain Euro. Le prochain
contre Malte, a priori d'un
d'un auditeur tchadien qu'on
connaît bien, Archeduc, il nous
dit, ben bientôt l'Italie elle
sera battue par le Tchad.
Voilà, bien envoyé mon cher
euh, Rémi Euh, il y a eu des
Cameroun italiens euh,
également en Coupe du monde, je
crois pas que vous ayez, vous
en ayez gagné beaucoup euh.
Ouais, mais sans au passage.
C'est vrai, c'est vrai équipe
italienne euh, qui en est
réduit à à nommer euh, Marco
Verratti capitaine, je veux
dire quelle tragédie euh, je
plaisante, mais euh, peut-elle
euh être complètement déclassé
aujourd'hui euh pourtant elle a
gagné le l'Euro. Donc on a on a
du mal à comprendre. Euh on
apprend que c'est plus une
grande nation et pourtant elle
est championne d'Europe en
titre, mais là on craint
qu'elle euh n'aille pas à
l'euro après avoir raté les
deux dernières coupes du monde,
vous en vous en pensez quoi
vous? Euh vous savez, vous avez
évoqué l'équipe d'Italie qui
justement gagne la Coupe du
monde en quatre-vingt-deux, qui
se retrouve dans la poule avec
le Cameroun. Hum. Et justement
qui va faire euh un but partout
avec le Cameroun, but de je
crois Bidarante est. Et cette
équipe n'avait pas des armes
offensives hein, pas seulement
que personne connaissait et qui
d'ailleurs qui avait fini
meilleur buteur mais cette
équipe avait un grand gardien
de but. Zof. Dinosaure. Et
cette équipe avait une grande
défense. Quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui l'équipe d'Italie,
vous allez bien sûr dire que le
milieu de terrain ou Jordino
n'est plus au niveau où vous
regardez vers Hati qui n'est
pas au niveau, mais surtout ce
qui est inquiétant, c'est que
l'équipe d'Italie a perdu ses
vertus. C'est-à-dire que ce
n'est plus l'époque euh de
Kelleni Bonucci passe décisif
dans le l'obtention du dernier
qui était un peu les euh les
vestiges du d'une culture
italienne du grand c'est-à-dire
la défense n'est pas bonne de
la rouma n'est pas rassurant et
ça fait de telle sorte que pour
moi aujourd'hui cette équipe
d'Italie faiblit beaucoup.
C'est vrai que la deuxième
mi-temps, si on essaie de
regarder les statistiques,
c'est l'Italie qui domine. Même
sur l'ensemble du match,
c'est-à-dire que parce que
l'Italie finit quand même avec
dix tirs. Oui. Et l'Angleterre
avec euh
Russie a gagné. C'est pour ça
que je dis que ceux qui
équipent d'Italie il faudrait
que **** reviennent à ces
premières vertus à savoir
défendre correctement et puis
lancer quelques banderilles
pour pouvoir euh c'était pas ça
le jeu de Mancini, c'était un
jeu offensif qui était plaisant
d'ailleurs. Hum hum. Mais en
s'appuyant sur des éléments de
qualité euh notamment
l'ossature de la Juventus où il
y avait beaucoup de joueurs qui
étaient encore euh compétitifs.
Or la Juventus c'est des est
aujourd'hui déclassé et les
autres clubs ont pratiquement
plus de joueurs italiens. Donc
euh c'est très compliqué pour
lui de faire Roberto Mancini,
Harry Ca à présent, que
Manchini a peut-être croisé euh
lorsqu'il entraînait en
première ligue. Nouveau but
pour le capitaine anglais hier,
donc on l'a dit sur penalty,
n'a pas raté la cible euh cette
fois. Harry Kain euh qui est
encore derrière euh et surtout
Allan Chira pour le titre de
meilleur buteur de l'histoire
de la euh première ligue mais
il est déjà le meilleur buteur
de l'histoire de Tottenham et
il est devenu hier le meilleur
buteur de l'histoire de la
sélection anglaise devant euh
Wayne euh Roné, vingt-et-une
euh réalisations cette saison
au championnat pour Harry Cain,
mais le vide ou presque en
Ligue des champions, et si on
ajoute son échec en en j'ai
parlé de ce qui s'est passé et
en en en Ligue des champions
aussi euh on a euh une sorte de
résumé de ce qu'est euh
Hurricane, c'est-à-dire un un
très grand joueur et euh en
même temps un palmarès euh vide
euh le désert de Gobi euh
clairement en termes de de
palmarès, il y a une Audi Cup
je crois, un tournoi traîner
quelque part et euh il a déjà
29 ans, donc Harry Kale, le
palmarès, le le paradoxe, pas
de palmarès, grands joueurs,
des records, moi je l'ai déjà
dit ici, je crois qu'il est en
train de faire une carrière à
Alan Shier. Alan au moins lui
était champion d'Angleterre
avec Black Bonn Rovers avant de
signer à Newcastle. Après plus
rien il empilait les buts en
première ligue avec la
sélection mais en terme de
trophée Alain Tireur n'a rien
eu quoi. Aujourd'hui Arrican
s'il veut gagner soit il va
quitter Tottenham soit il va
euh quitter la Premier League
tout court, aller parce que il
est il a été euh courtisé
récemment par le Bayern de
Munich. Je crois que il doit
signer dans ses grands clubs
pour et là il un très bon
joueur pour être un grand
joueur, c'est-à-dire euh euh
dans la galaxie des de joueurs
comme Rouny qui a tout gagné
avec il faudrait qu'il quitte
les sports moi je trouve
admirable ce que fait Kane
parce que alors même si c'est
un peu à son corps défendant en
tout cas euh question qu'il
aille à Manchester City, il
reste à Tottenham euh dans le
club euh ben qui qui est ou qui
l'incarne parfaitement euh et
il essaye de toujours d'être
plus performant avec cette
équipe ils sont quand même
allés en finale de la Ligue des
champions, ils ont ils sont
quand même régulièrement euh
dans les quatre premiers du
championnat d'Angleterre.
Effectivement il manque un
titre mais Chireur aujourd'hui
on en parle encore, même si il
a un palmarès assez dégarni
hum. Euh alors que il y a plein
de gars qui ont été champions
d'Angleterre euh ou qui ont
gagné la Cup euh qu'on a
oublié. Donc euh moi ce que je
trouve, ce que je trouve que
arrive à faire Kein en
maintenant cette équipe de
Tottenham euh au plus haut
niveau euh c'est remarquable
dans un autre sens. Rémi c'est
un perdant, un romantique, un
perdant romantique euh Harry
Cain? Oui bon, quand on voit
les garer la Necker qui sont
restés dans l'histoire de
l'Angleterre, je ne sais pas ce
qu'on retiendra de Arican. Ou
bien celui qui savait tirer les
penalties en pleine lucarne. Ou
bien celui qui savait beaucoup
perdre. Moi je crois quand même
que Arrican a aussi un défaut,
c'est que ce n'est pas un un
attaquant complet il peut jouer
qu'en pivot contrairement
actuellement à vous en fait euh
quelqu'un qui donne des coups
de coude et qui distribue le
jeu comme il est euh est-ce que
est-ce que vous vous rendez
compte? Du match de Harrican
hier s'il ne marquait pas le
penalty mais il avait deux sur
deux pas le juger et moi je me
dis si jusqu'à présent Harrican
ne parvient vraiment pas à
partir dans un club consistant
et d'ailleurs ça a été la même
chose au niveau de la coupe du
monde cela veut dire quand même
qu'il y a certains manquements
peut-être que il faudrait que
Arrican puisse se réinvent
comme un attaquant moderne. Moi
je ne le trouve pas comme un
attaquant moderne, il peut être
un bon renard de surface mais
il n'est pas un attaquant
complet, style Benzema
aujourd'hui qui donc les
équipes ont encore besoin ou il
n'est pas aussi puissant que ça
parce que Benzema a eu un zéro
l'autre jour. Donc quel
exemple? Doit pas être une il
en reçoit mais bien sûr euh il
sa Coupe du monde elle a été
formidable. À part quand même
est-ce
que ça ça parle un peu
d'Harry Cain nous dit meilleur
buteur partout mais son trophée
euh quel malheureux euh
Harrican doit faire un tour en
Afrique nous dit euh Jérôme
Boss au Tchad je ne sais pas
Michel est marabout quoi. Non
mais c'est vrai il a quand même
joué la finale de l'Euro euh il
aurait pu la gagner bah non
finale de Ligue des Champions
perdue enfin il y a un moment
faut les gagner les matchs
décisifs face à Hugo Lloris si
il met le penalty et au Sénégal
combien de finales a joué
l'Angleterre avant Harry Cain
ces dernières années? Aucune.
Aucune. Euh combien de finales
a joué Tottenham avant Harry
donc c'est déjà exceptionnel ce
qu'il a réussi à faire avec son
club et avec cette équipe
nationale. Alors il leur manque
un petit quelque chose. Bon, ça
sera peut-être pour une
prochaine fois. Et peut-être
que ce sera dans un prochain
club parmi les équipes qui
pourraient courtiser Hurricane
cet été, le Bayern Munich. La
transition est donc naturelle.
Oui c'est le le coup de
tonnerre. Et Aubert Munich euh
c'est dommage pour lui mais
Harrican il aurait pu être
entraîné par un un coach qui
aurait presque euh son âge
hein. C'est la touche euh
Julian Nagelsman hurler sur des
joueurs parfois plus vieux que
lui. Attention fulgurante euh
entraîneur d'Hoffenheim a même
pas 30 ans puis et puis euh
acheté vingt-cinq millions plus
d'un-million en tout cas par le
Bayern Munich euh le jeune
coach allemand Guyane Nagalsman
devait euh réinventer le métier
d'entraîneur et pas seulement
en Allemagne hein, pas
seulement euh avec son contrat
longue du euh sur le bon
bavarois mais euh en Europe
hein, c'était le nouveau
Guardiola, patatra, tout s'est
écroulé avec euh son renvoi du
Bayern Munich alors que
s'annonce un sprint final
passionnant euh pour euh le
géant bavarois euh Rémy Gonaud,
comment vous vous expliquez que
le le Bayern ait pris la
décision de se séparer de
Julian Nagalsman, alors que
tout allait bien ou presque?
Simplement la la première place
euh qui pour l'instant n'est
pas assurée en en Bundesliga.
Euh il faut se dire que hum
déjà il est il était en chute
libre et
c'est attends, tu vas dire ça
l'histoire seulement cette
histoire je vais vous donner
les ce n'est pas toi Rémy
Gonna. Non
tu commences à essayer
après euh après après vous vous
corrigerez si vous si vous en
sentez le besoin. Bien sûr que
il va prendre la Ligue des
champions et tout et tout c'est
vrai. C'est huit matchs mais on
n'a pas recruté ce gars pour
venir donner des leçons au
football au FC Barcelone parce
que j'aurais souhaité qu'il
soit là parce que avec le FC
Barcelone c'est onze buts euh
quatre victoires et puis bien
évidemment zéro but encaissé.
Ça c'est bon pour le Bayern.
Il vient de perdre contre une
équipe qui était presque
dixième, qui n'a pas un
excellent et surtout que même
l'année dernière quand il avait
euh euh Lewandowski, il avait
de la peine à battre cette
équipe-là. Et au-delà de ça, il
l'a perdu pratiquement 10
points par rapport à. Ce qui
n'est pas possible. Elle est le
Bayern se retrouve quand même
devant une équipe qu'on appelle
Manchester City. Qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire? Puisque c'est
une équipe c'est un prochain
match en Ligue des champions.
Lorsqu'on voit aujourd'hui
l'équipe du Bayern qui prend
considérablement des buts parce
qu'il faut quand même se dire
que le Bayern aujourd'hui c'est
27 buts encaissés. En
vingt-sept, cinq matchs. Alors
imaginez que vous allez
rencontrer les Allans et
consors. Or, Thomas Tuchel,
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
a une organisation défensive et
on l'a vu, il est arrivé à
Chelsea en cours de saison, il
a remporté la Ligue des
champions. Alors c'est vrai que
la la touche pour raconter la
touche c'est aussi d'être
remplacé par il faut il faut
dire ce qui se passe. Le le
c'est c'est un club où il y a
euh une très forte culture des
des joueurs et notamment des
joueurs allemands et des
joueurs qu'on qui reste au club
longtemps. Les piliers de cette
équipe moi j'ai les d'air. On
peut les appeler comme ça.
C'est comme à Paris Newer et
c'est euh Thomas Muller et
maintenant Joshua Kimmic. C'est
eux les patrons du club. Et euh
les entraîneurs passent. Il y a
beaucoup d'entraîneurs qui sont
passés au Bayern cette dernière
saison. Et non des moindres par
exemple. Et et c'est important
d'avoir dans la poche. Or,
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé?
Voilà, ce qui s'est passé que
Rémy Gonot ne vous a pas dit,
c'est que Julian Nagalsman il a
une petite amie qui était la
journaliste du Bilt, qui
couvrait le Bayern. Hum. Donc,
cette Fila euh, il a le droit
d'avoir une vie sentimentale,
surtout un un jeune homme de 35
ans. Donc, du coup, le Bilt a
sorti la jeune femme de la du
club. Elle ne couvre plus le
club. Mais qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé? Forcément elle elle sait
d'où viennent les informations
qui fuitent, qui arrivent au
Bild et lui eh bien il déplore
que certaines informations
arrivent dans la presse. Oui il
a fait une batterie de la
taupe. Voilà et il a viré
Tapalovic l'entraîneur des
gardiens. Qui est très proche
de la presse en est plein, donc
du coup les anciens se sont
montés contre Naguelsman et
là-dessus les dirigeants,
Oliver Kahn maintenant et
Hassan Saliamitz qui sont
d'anciens joueurs du club. Ils
ont dû trancher entre les les
cadres de du vestiaire et ils
ont qu'ils euh
et là la situation de crise et
c'est pas la première fois
qu'on a une crise comme ça au
Bayern de Munich je vous
rappelle que euh après une
défaite au Parc des Princes
qu'on ne comprenait pas contre
le PSG, Ancelloti a pris ses
bagages du jour au lendemain.
Donc ce sont des choses qui
arrivent au Bayern et et Neyna
Galsman en fait à son tour
l'expérience. Et c'est le FC
Hollywood hein, c'est le surnom
qui a longtemps été celui du
Bayard Mané c'est une bonne
nouvelle du Roman Gara. Le
départ de Ninger Sman l'arrivée
donc de Thomas c'est qui a fait
signer Sadio Mané dans cette
équipe, il a été le voir au
mois de mars dernier en
Angleterre et il lui avait dit
euh le projet de jeu c'est ça
et tout va tourner autour de
toi aujourd'hui avec Tuchel
l'avenir maintenant c'est
Tuchel, est-ce que c'est une
évidence? Je sais pas. Après
euh Tuchel c'est un adepte du
trois quatre trois, Sadio Mané
pourrait retrouver son côté
gauche, il pourrait rayonner
même avec Thomas Tuchel, ils
ont viré un crack pour un autre
crack. Avis a tout résumé. Au
Bayern il y a des Classiques,
il y a des leaders de
vestiaires qui ont viré
Guardiola, qui ont viré
Angeloti et qui ont eu la tête
de Nagal Seman. Et c'est pas
fini. Don Gardela a été viré?
Bah presque il a poussé à
repartir faire le bilan de
Guardiola qui est parti en 2016
du du Bayern Munich. Simplement
Thomas Tourel, la dernière fois
qu'il a pris une équipe euh en
cours de siège il a gagné la
Ligue des Champions quelques
mois plus tard. Sachant que
déjà Thomas Tuchel il est parti
fâché avec le fâché avec les
dirigeants du PSG, fâché avec
les dirigeants de Chelsea,
alors que il vient dans un
panier à crabe, le Bayern de
Munich et lui il a c'est c'est
c'est un sanguinaire aussi euh
non non non c'est les deux.
Mais pacifier le vestiaire du
Bayern avec euh le Bayern le
voulait. Le Bayern le voulait,
avant qu'il vienne au PSG
puisque c'est comme ça qu'on a
su qu'il allait venir au PSG,
c'est parce que Carlos
Dromening a lâché à ce
moment-là ben on voulait
prendre euh Tuchel,
malheureusement il a déjà signé
ailleurs, en l'occurrence au
PSG. Donc c'est une une longue
histoire et d'ailleurs Tuchel
ces derniers, depuis qu'il
Chelsea vivait à Munich donc
l'un des meilleurs entraîneurs
allemands euh je vais voir
comment ils vont. Mais où
Lyonnais il y est plus hein
euh pardon voilà. En tout cas
il y a des grands anciens très
charismatiques c'est c'est
aussi la la formule Bayern. Un
auditeur qui nous résume tout
ça euh KBWJ il gagne tous ses
matchs en Ligue des champions,
il élimine le PSG, il se fait
limogé et pendant ce temps-là,
Christophe Galtier lui reste à
Paris, il fait bronzette au
PSG. Vous allez nous enflammer
cette fin de café des sports
alors qu'on doit cet été il
risque d'avoir pas mal de
propositions hein, on parle
déjà de lui à Tottenham
d'ailleurs. Peut-être à Paris
hein. Ouais c'est un coup
d'arrêt quand même dans une
ascension qui était
exceptionnelle et et
fulgurante, 35 ans. Ouais. Euh
déjà pas mal d'années de
coaching de des performances en
Ligue des champions assez
formidables avec des il y a il
est passé trois fois hein.
Qu'on qu'on lui souhaite euh
comme on dit? À Vedersen?
Guyane et puis euh euh
et les cartons? Bien sûr.
Carton jaune! Carton jaune. Ouh
là là là là, carton rouge,
carton rouge. Dans la
conclusion. Carton vert. Rien à
dire. Nos auditeurs ont du
talent mais pas que. Ils ont
aussi euh Internet, une bonne
connexion, un téléphone et
WhatsApp. Bonsoir Café des
sports, je m'appelle Bachir et
je vous suis depuis au Sénégal
je voudrais donner un carton
vert foncé aux équipes
nationales du Sénégal de foot
qui auront porté tous les
trophées continentaux euh
Cannes, et même le championnat
d'Afrique des sourds mieux.
Bonjour Radio Foot
International c'est la page
depuis l'extrême nord du
Cameroun. On cartonne vers
versé à Christiano Ronaldo
appelle son double d'hier.
Christian c'est pas l'âge qui
compte. Mais c'est le talent.
Il y a un proverbe africain qui
dit la vieille marmite fait
toujours des bons soins. Tu
salues comme ça Rémi prouve
toujours toujours que il est le
plus fort du monde
face au réellement triste. Pour
savoir ça. On joue Radio Foot
International, moi c'est Junior
Brazzaville. Je tiens à donner
le carton rouge, le carton
rouge à le prince Africaine. Le
prince Hawken qui qui ne cesse
pas de battre des records mais
qui ne pense pas à remplir son
armoire avec tout ce qui est
là-bas tout comme record, il
aurait dû gagner soit un
championnat, soit une Champions
League. Il est temps de penser
à remplir son armoire.
Je m'appelle je vous suis
depuis la RDC
je donne sa bonne soeur à Emma.
D'ailleurs pour donner je vous
souhaite un bonne émission.
Salut Radio Foot International,
moi c'est ma TV depuis les
États-Unis et ce matin je
voudrais donner un carton vert
à un très grand monsieur
d'Afrique. Et pour reconnaître
la grandeur l'immensité de ce
monsieur, il faut être togolais
vivant à l'étranger. Parce que
quand vous êtes Togolais
l'étranger, les gens vous
demandent quelle est votre
origine? Où d'où venez vous et
vous dites Togo euh beaucoup de
personnes ne s'y reconnaissent
pas. Pour ceux qui s'y
connaissent en football, dès
que vous dites à tout le monde
a la même réaction. Oh yes!
Togo, Adebayo, Adebay C'est je
ne peux pas compter le nombre
de fois que cela m'est arrivé.
C'est là j'ai reconnu la
grandeur de ce monsieur. Bonne
retraite. Bonjour, rendez-vous
international. Moi c'est depuis
Lomé. Et j'ai deux cartons
verra donner rapidement. Le
premier c'est un quart d'heure
à toute l'équipe de euh Radio
Foot International à N'Golo
Valente, Xavier Barré, vos
techniciens, tout le monde,
tout le monde, tout le monde. À
même le poulet donné quand on
veut. Le deuxième carton vert,
je vais le donner entre le
Comté, l'entraîneur de toute
nomme. Il a très bien dit la
vérité, c'est un carton 25% et
j'aimerais que le le staff
technique ou bien les
entraîneurs du du du prennent
exemple sur entre nous compter,
dire la vérité. Salut, salut,
c'est depuis la Mauritanie.
Aujourd'hui j'ai deux cartons
verts. Le premier cartons vert
appartient à l'équipe de Radio
Foot International. Pourquoi?
C'est sur cette émission que
j'ai entendu Olivier Dubois et
de kidnappé au Mali. Et à
chaque fois, j'entends la
solidarité de cette équipe pour
la libération d'Olivier
Desbois. Le deuxième carton
vert appartient à toute
personnes qui ont participé
pour la libération d'Olivier
Dubois. Donc euh merci et bon
Café des sports à toutes et à
tous. Merci et bon week-end.
Oui effectivement hein carton
vert à à Olivier Dubois et qui
écoutez euh RFI, RFI qui a qui
a contribué à le à le soutenir
et carton à à Annie euh Gasnier
et effectivement qui a aussi
euh oeuvré à à faire euh
connaître le sort d'Olivier
Dubois et qui euh reviendra
très bientôt euh Annie Gassini
à la tête de cette émission les
cartons autour de la table euh
la colère Ah oui, en carton
rouge, et il est décerné aux
responsables politiques de
l'APR, c'est le parti du
président Macky Sall, ils ont
confisqué tous les tickets du
match Sénégal Mozambique qu'ils
distribuent exclusivement aux
militants de leur parti pour
éviter que leur leader Macky
Sall ne soit conspué au stade
aujourd'hui et une démarche qui
laisse les amateurs euh de foot
et qui n'arrive pas à trouver
le fameux sésame euh sur le
marché. S'ils veulent pas que
Macky Sall soit constitué,
c'est simple, qu'il de de
vouloir briguer un troisième
mandat et qu'il respecte sa
parole. C'est aussi simple que
ça. Le coup de gueule applaudit
par euh Ray Rémy Gonot
justement c'est à vous. Et vous
êtes plutôt gentil aujourd'hui?
Très gentil avec euh un carton
vert qui est donné à un joueur
qu'on appelle Emmanuel Maop.
Presque personne le connaît
parce que il a été appelé par
euh celui qu'on appelle euh
**** son? Le sélection
pour venir suppléer qui
Alors l'histoire de ce monsieur
extraordinaire, c'est que il
est parti jouer comme gardien
de but en Guinée équatoriale en
deuxième division. Emmanuel
Maho. Mais il est pas gardien.
Gardien du but, suivez-moi
bien. Il va là-bas comme
gardien de but et il trouve que
son équipe est en train de
descendre justement en
troisième division, il dit à
son coach, s'il te plaît, je
veux jouer à l'attaque. Le
coach lui dit, ah bon, tu peux
jouer à la même moi la CAQ on
le bat à la CAQ en 15 matchs le
gars claque 38 buts et l'année
suivante eh bien on reprend en
première division en première
division le gars devient encore
meilleur buteur du championnat
de Guinée équatoriale et le
Cameroun se rend compte que
mais tiens il y a un attaquant
là-bas et on le prend dans le
canon de Yaoundé actuellement
il est à dix buts donc il est
le meilleur euh euh attaquant
du championnat camerounais en
ce moment et vous voyez donc
quand le Cameroun aujourd'hui
des attaquants à gauche et à
droite, on en trouve pas à la
dimension de Éric et puis on a
donc pris l'ancien gardien de
but reconverti en attaquant
qu'on appelle Emmanuel Macron
comme le dit un proverbe
africain mieux vaut un boeuf
qui donne des coups de cornes
que le câble est vide joli le
proverbe et la trajectoire
d'Emmanuel qui profite aussi
des absences de Toko Ekambi,
Aboubakar. Frédéric Sutaud. Euh
carton jaune, les clubs euh de
foot féminin des champions des
Lyonnaises, les Parisiennes,
quart de finale aller cette
semaine, elles jouent à
domicile euh à domicile et les
les deux ont perdu, les
Lyonnaises championnes d'Europe
en titre, euh huit titres hein
de de championnes d'Europe euh
sur les dernières décennies,
battus par Chelsea euh un un
zéro, les Parisiennes, pas
mieux, battues paroles un à
zéro, le retour c'est la
semaine prochaine, mais on a
l'impression que l'âge d'or du
foot féminin français en club
est en train de passer dehors
du football masculin. On verra.
Finalise de la dernière coupe
du monde. Hein? Mais peut-être
qu'un avantage compétitif est
en train de se réduire Je je
l'en de France euh masculine et
je donne même un carton vert à
Antoine Griezmann, pourquoi?
Parce que je pense qu'au regard
de ce qu'il a fait ces
dernières années, il a toujours
été à 100% pour l'équipe de
France, il s'est même sacrifié
lors de la dernière Coupe du
monde en se repositionnant
comme milieu de terrain, alors
que c'est pas forcément son
poste à l'origine. Et je pense
que il pouvait légitimement
espérer le brassard de
capitaine puisqu'il totalise
cent cent dix-sept sélections.
Mais euh Mbappé est un garçon
bourré de talents, très bon
communicant, mais je comprends
l'amertume de Griezmann, alors
je lui donne un carton vert
d'encouragement. Et à mon avis,
il va se teindre les cheveux en
verre euh, pour vous remercier.
Mon cher Xavier Barré, le
carton de Radio Foot, avant de
se quitter, il est vert et il
est un peu nostalgique
puisqu'on dit au revoir à l'un
des plus beaux joueurs de ces
dernières années, mais
Zutosile, l'Allemand a pris sa
retraite. Les mauvaises langues
diront qu'il avait déjà pris
ses distances avec le football
de niveau depuis pas mal de
temps. Ce ne sont pas ces
dernières années en Turquie
qu'on va retenir. Son autre
pays, la Turquie, plutôt sa
magique, sa qualité de passe
exceptionnelle, la manière dont
il a mené euh le jeu du Real
d'Arsenal et puis évidemment de
l'équipe allemande, championne
du monde en 2014, il avait
notamment au Brésil, fait
trembler les filets lors du
huitième de finale de légende
contre l'Algérie. Voilà, le
café des sports se referme,
Radio Foot revient lundi en
attendant, excellente soirée,
l'écoute de RFI ou en regardant
France 2quatre.